despite their big gains in the house and
the midterms Democrats still may not get
it they have a new line they've been
testing it out alright ready for this
there now the smartest people in the
room who have all the answers even if
you're too stupid to understand it one
of the things that we Democrats have a
really hard time is connecting to
people's hearts instead of here we're
really good at shoving out all the
information that touch people here but
not here we Democrats know so much that
is true and we have to kind of tell
everybody how smart we are and and so we
have a tendency to to be very left brain
now let's do you think this is some
isolated idea all right that we're just
so smart we have trouble connecting with
you it's actually something that shared
fairly widely and two of the latest
forbearers by the way of the Democratic
Party
you really think Donald Trump has the
temperament to be commander in chief
imagine him in the Oval Office facing a
real crisis he just says well I'm gonna
I'm gonna negotiate a better deal
what magic wand do you have and usually
the answer is he doesn't have an answer
this office has a way of waking yep his
positions or predispositions that don't
match up with reality
he will find shaken up pretty quick okay
the obvious implication being that
Donald Trump and those Americans who
voted for him parties a bunch of dumb
rubes now let's face it when Trump won
in 2016 like you could see Obama they're
still shell-shocked back in November
2016 well he embarrassed Trump
embarrassed a lot of the so-called
experts the consultants the pollsters
the strategists all the big thinkers in
the establishment class so feeling
subtly diminished they lashed out at
Trump belittling his intelligence the
problem here is that the president
doesn't read we know that he's
remarkable how little confidence Donald
Trump's own lawyers have in him that
they think he's too stupid to stand sit
across the table with Robert mullet
almost caveman like Fred Flintstone
running the country it's a man without
curiosity it's a man who doesn't read
and it's it's a man with an attention
span of a rabid tsetse fly okay that's
going back a mark shields oh they said
similar things by the way about Reagan
until he died of course and then they
all pretended that they never said any
of the main stuff they said about him
for his two terms in office liberals
claim to be for the little guy you know
they're the champions of the average
person but they're really elitist snobs
at heart morning down in New York Times
columns used to write these pieces
mocking the cultural and culinary taste
of Bush 41 and Barbara you know he ate
pork rinds and the two of them watched
things like America's Funniest Home
Videos on TV on Sunday nights the
subtext was always look at the bushes
Ivy League Blue Bloods but still
unsophisticated and frankly not all that
smart well here's a newsflash for
everybody no one who becomes president
is dumb
especially not Trump who managed to beat
not one but two political dynasties to
win the White House remember all the
dire predictions made by all those
political and business savants about a
trump presidency if the unlikely event
happens and Trump wins you will see a
market crash of historic proportions in
the event Donald wins I have no doubt in
my mind the the market tanks Donald
Trump is moving us toward World War 3
the lack of a diplomatic and serious
engagement strategy in my view has us
sliding toward war by next summer we can
just play this all night long let's not
even have a show because that is really
entertaining Democrats and their allies
imply that they have a monopoly on
intelligence and brain
but if that's true why have they screwed
things up so badly when they had the
chance to fix them while Trump
identified the threats for instance
posed by China and has challenged them
who can forget Bill Clinton pushing for
China's acceptance on the world stage
with his misguided WTO push this
agreement is a good deal for America our
products will gain better access to
China's market the China gains no new
market access to the United States will
gain tough new safeguards against surges
of imports and maintain the strongest
possible rules against dumping products
that have hurt Americans in the past oh
my god
Rhodes Scholar Yale undergrad Yale Law
School and like many others he didn't
see the obvious coming China has
manipulated in distorted world markets
engaged in blatant ransacking of our
intellectual property and dumped heavily
subsidized products into the United
States leading to the loss of millions
of US jobs the CEO of Minnesota's
cambria it makes quartz countertops told
us earlier this week how China targets
US manufacturers for the sole purpose of
destroying them and then dominating the
market they're subsidized by their
government in the People's Republic of
China is not a friendly participant in a
free enterprise economy in America they
subsidize their companies they run their
banks their state-owned and they're
going after American manufacturing but
no worries because Democrats have all
the answers now remember President Obama
assuring us by the way that his cabinet
would be staffed with the best and the
brightest we're on track to flip the
switch on October 1st we are on track to
have the marketplace up and running on
October 1st I'm confident that we we
will be up and running in on track on
October 1st
says the site is working the way we want
it to certainly the president
acknowledged that yesterday no one could
be more frustrated I am an the president
that this isn't smooth all right a
hundred and twenty million dollars or so
right to get that website it wasn't more
and they couldn't get a website working
like a freshman at MIT could get the
website working who can forget the Obama
administration's foreign policy flops
again these are the smart people
remember amazing Hirono said we're so
we're too smart for our own good arm
when he designated the Muslim
Brotherhood as moderate Islamists in
Egypt and he called Iran's president
Hwanhee
a moderate reformer we are encouraged
that President rouhani received from the
Iranian people a mandate to pursue a
more moderate course Iran's genuine
commitment to go down a different path
will be good for the region and the
world it's been awesome so far and how
about all the geopolitical geniuses at
Hillary State Department allowing our
ambassador to travel to Benghazi when we
knew about repeated security threats in
an unstable situation on the ground he
and three others ended up dead Trump
removed the rose-colored glasses and
what he did is he confronted the rogue
powers in the region as they exist
Trump's foreign policy is more pragmatic
and prudent he doesn't believe in
nation-building nor does he believe
passivity is the answer in the face of
real threats but the Democrats they feel
like come on they have the wind at their
backs now forget all this stuff that
happened all our predictions that came
out well they didn't come out to be true
at all but they feel like they have a
head of steam now and maybe you can kind
of understand it they picked up 40 seats
in the House but right now what I'm
seeing there is very little little
evidence that they've learned much about
America why they voted in the first
place for Donald Trump and why they
still support so many of his policies
especially on trade and immigration and
for all the Democrats star power they
couldn't win the big races in Florida
Texas or Georgia why not I'll tell you
why in part
have not come to terms with the fact
that they're decades of errors pave the
way for Donald Trump but I'll tell you
this at least Senator Claire McCaskill
of course she lost her re-election bid
she seemed to have learned something
telling NPR I don't think my vote
against Kavanagh hurt me as much as the
spectacle that occurred there were
mistakes made by my party in terms of
how that was handled well I'll say the
bright lights of the Democratic Party
though they thought that the American
people would rally behind them and they
set about to destroy the life of a man
who actually is brilliant and one of the
finest judges in America well instead
most fair minds minded people maybe they
didn't go to Yale Law School they saw
the campaign of the Democrats a campaign
of personal destruction for what it was
insidious I don't know what the next two
years is going to bring but before you
sweat the warnings of the expert class
remember just how much they screwed up
over the past thirty years or so and
that's the angle